ضياع وعدم يقين يعيشه سكان مستوطنات غلاف
غزه وهم الذين تقدم لهم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في العاده مغريات كبيره من
اجل جاذبهم للسكن فيها والبقاء حاجزا
جغرافيا
وديموغرافيا بين القطاع والضفه الغربيه
يمنع مستقبلا قيام دوله فلسطينيه متصله
الاطراف
في المقابل تشكل هذه المستوطنات عسكريا
خاسره رخوه للاحتلال وكانت منذ الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من غزه هدفا لصواريخ الفصائل
التي تطورت ترسانتها لتصبح ابعد مدن واقوى
تاثيرا منذ ان بدات اسرائيل الغارات
الجويه على قطاع غزه يوم الثلاثاء اطلقت
غرفه العمليات المشتركه للمقاومه اكثر من
الف صاروخ على اسرائيل وفقا لارقام
اسرائيليه رسميه في سديرات الاكثر تضررا
اغلق العديد من الاعمال التجاريه والمدارس
وفر السكان قله قليله من الباقين فيها
تغامر بالابتعاد عن غرف الحمايه ضد
الانفجار لانني
اين من المفترض ان اذهب الصين من يحتاجني
اين ساذهب تل ابيب الوضع هناك ايضا غير
مستقر
انا خائف جدا اعيش بالقرب من هنا اتمنى ان
يحل السلام والحب حيث لا يمكننا ان نستمر
في هذا الصراع وخلال عمليات الاجلاء
الحكومي التي جاءت اثناء ايام التصعيد
السابقه كان وجود المستوطنين
مربكا حتى للحكومه الاسرائيليه التي
تعاملت مع ذعرهم واستيائهم من وضع
الاقتصاد وحال الخدمات المعطله كعبئ وليس
كحاجه